jetzt aber mal ganz schlechte
nachrichten für deutschlands schulen der
sogenannte digital packt liegt seit
dieser woche auf 1 5 milliarden will der
bund eigentlich den ländern für die
digitalisierung unserer schulen geben
wäre dringend nötig so wie die meisten
von denen ausgestattet sind wissen sie
leider haben die bundesländer aber jetzt
die notbremse gezogen unter anderem weil
sie zu viel einmischung des bundes in
ihre fantastische bildungspolitik
befürchten dann lieber gar kein geld
schön blöd dabei könnte das digitale
lernen so toll werden meint friedemann
weise telekolleg digitale pädagogik mit
friedemann bösel digitale pädagogik da
stellen sich fragen wie viele likes
braucht man für die versetzung kann ich
während des schuljahrs den provider
wechseln und muss sich oma jetzt extra
einen ereader kaufen wenn sie das
zeugnis lesen will
das digitale klassenzimmer ein
herzensthema unserer kanzlerin kein
wunder als physikerin hat sie natürlich
ein händchen für alles technische aber
jetzt liegt der digital paar kleider auf
eis wegen der länder da ist es wieder
schulpolitik ist ländersache
wenn das überall so wer stell dir vor
die bahnen der ausländer sache dann
würden täglich tausende von bahnkunden
ist okay schlechtes beispiel
dabei hätte die digitale schule nur
vorteile
nie wieder versiffte schuldlos die
schüler lassen einfach ihre vr brillen
auf wenn sie aufs klo gehen
das ist es zwar immer noch total dreckig
aber in der brille sieht aus wie ein
luxus ressort alles wäre besser es gibt
endlich unangekündigte modediktat der
einhorn weihnachtsbaum feuerwehr sie
hatte beim friseur aubergine aubergine
500 kern gehacktes kostenberg verkaufen
und der deutsch leistungskurs ließ dann
die leiden des jungen routers kaste der
prozessor und natürlich das verlorene
passwort der katharina blum oder
biologie da spielen wir nur noch fahren
will
außer sie haben sexualkunde da schaltet
der lehrer einfach die google
kindersicherung aus und fertig und für
alle die jetzt scheinen wir brauchen
nicht mehr tablets wir brauchen mehr
lehrer denken sie mal darüber nach wer
in deutschland alles lehrer werden darf
ich sag mal so ein tablet wird niemals
das vierte reich ausrufen so ich muss
jetzt los ich bin nebenher noch eure
lehrer an der ersten digitalen
waldorfschule
ja wir tanzen nur noch nullen und einsen
[Musik]
[Applaus]